(audience cheering)
♪ You're the only one,
only one I got my eyes on ♪
♪ I don't need, I don't need
but a second, then I'm gone ♪
♪ But when the snow starts falling ♪
♪ Christmas ain't far and I feel it ♪
♪ In my heart, in my bones,
you're the secret I hold ♪
♪ Can you keep it ♪
♪ If you ever need me ♪
♪ If you find yourself alone ♪
♪ Christmas is a season ♪
♪ The lights like you glow all year long ♪
♪ Nothing has changed ♪
♪ I still wish you could be ♪
♪ Wrapped up in my arms ♪
♪ Spending Christmas with me ♪
♪ When it gets cold is
when I notice the most ♪
♪ With all the lights on the trees ♪
♪ Even Christmas can't
compete with your glow ♪
♪ Did you know, did you know ♪
♪ Christmas can't compete with your ♪
♪ Just so you know ♪
♪ Nothing has changed ♪
♪ I still wish you could be ♪
♪ Wrapped up in my arms ♪
♪ Spending Christmas with me ♪
♪ When it gets cold is
when I notice the most ♪
♪ With all the lights on the trees ♪
♪ Even Christmas can't
compete with your glow ♪
♪ It's a shame you can't see ♪
♪ Even Christmas can't
compete with your glow ♪
- Ay!
(audience cheering)